Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
Thank you for waking up and joining us for our 52nd episode today!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan.
Was it a Pero Sighting?
Did we see Pero in all Ruffians?
Apparently!
One Ruffian did see Pero.
Let's see where he was found!
De-den!
Wait.
Pero.
Pero's trapped there underneath the ice.
He's not having fun, huh?
He must be cold.
Look closely.
Closely at his face.
Deep into his eyes.
Ruffians.
Can you hear his screams?
I can.
And something else.
This Ruffian suggests that Pero went for a swim.
And that, you know, he made a mistake because he didn't realize it was freezing out.
That's a big mistake.
Yeah, they end off the tweet with a, I hope he is alright, period.
I don't know.
That sounds sort of suspicious.
Why?
Maybe it's not a genuine concern.
He could be like, I hope he has a right exclamation mark!
I hope he's good there!
It's almost like you tricked him.
Try to trap him there.
I didn't want to say it, but... You wouldn't do that, right?
Right!
Well, uh, Pero, you know he's very abundantly round and snow-colored, so he does pretty well in the winter already, but... Let's hope he escapes your icy pool soon!
Yeah.
You make sure nothing else gets dropped in there, okay?
Yeah, yeah, it's a hazard.
And you!
Stay warm yourself too, okay?
BAU BAU!
Pero be good.
Oh boy, oh boy.
BAU BAU.
Well, you know, it's officially the holiday season, Ruffians.
It is!
And to celebrate, the long-awaited hololive Christmas voice packs are out!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
You know, and of course, of course,
FUWAMOCO went participating in it!
We did our best to record them both in English and Japanese.
So we hope that you'll check both of them out and spend Christmas together with us.
We always have so much fun with the voice packs so we hope that you enjoy them as much as we do too.
Oh boy!
Thank you!
Thank you
And also, we know how hard all of Advent like to record both in English and Japanese.
So we hope that you'll check them out, okay?
It's not everyday you get to hear them speaking in Japanese.
I mean, we, we sometimes, sometimes speak in Japanese.
But you know, all the other Advent members, not that often.
Look at Nerissa there!
So cute!
I wonder what her feelings were when it was getting taken like that.
But you can take out samples on the website too, okay?
Right!
Samples!
I love samples.
Stamples.
That's what you said.
BAU BAU!
Voice box is fun.
There's more exciting news about the fun stuff!
Ina-senpai!
Ina-senpai is having her birthday CD concert!
BAU BAU!
Ina-senpai dunk!
The concert's gonna be on Saturday, December 9th at 5PM PT or 10AM JST.
Ino-senpai's birthday was back in May, so it's a bit of a belated birthday.
Belated birthday, but still very, very happy.
Nonetheless, it's super exciting for all of us, especially the takodachi, too.
We're excited to see what she's going to do and what she might be performing as well.
We really love Ino-san's voice and her atmosphere, but I really, really love her dancing as well.
I do too!
I want to see it!
Don't miss it, okay, Ruffians?
We'll be live right after with Super Mario World.
As soon as it ends, too.
Mario Bros Wonder, which one is it?
What did you say?
Super Mario Wonder and Mario Bros Wonder.
I thought you said Mario Kart Wonder.
That's not right.
It's not right.
We're with the Mario Wonder.
Mario Brothers Wonder.
Okay, thank you.
BAU BAU!
Not just that, you know, there's a lot of exciting things going on.
And this one, we kind of talked about it about two weeks ago.
Sort of recently.
Yeah, but hololive right now currently has an official shop for a limited time in Tokyo Station!
Yeah!
In Tokyo Character Street.
Some images.
Yeah, a pop-up store.
It's located in the basement of Tokyo Station.
And yeah, that's part of the Tokyo Character Street.
You know, it's filled with stores of famous brands like Hello Kitty, Pokemon, Pretty Cure, you know?
Pretty Cure!
All those cool things.
And you can find Ai-senpai is the Tokyo Tourism Ambassador.
You know, Mikochi-senpai, Karin-senpai, Gura-senpai.
And they're there to greet you with new goodies!
And you know, you can find other merch from other hololive members there as well, too!
But!
We talked about that before, but!
Actually!
Starting on the 6th.
That's like tomorrow in Japan, right?
No.
Yeah!
Because it just became the 5th.
I guess it is tomorrow.
But tomorrow, yes!
You can find advent there too, but only if you're lucky.
Yeah, with every purchase of 3,300 yen, maybe $30, you might be able to get a special novelty card with an advent member or reglass member on it.
Unfortunately, there isn't any Advent merch there to buy.
But we do really hope that there will be merch for Adventrix to get their paws on in the future.
You know, we're still new so I guess it can't be helped.
Merchandise.
Advent merchandise.
Actually, those novelty cards.
Those are the very first place ever that you can see our signatures, Ruffians.
Our signatures!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Ruffians, we know how many are printed, so good luck!
Yeah.
You might also be able to hear the Regulus members doing in-store announcements when they're too doing this limited period of time, you know?
Like, oh, please check out this, or oh, I'm this member, you know?
Those kind of things.
Yeah.
Don't you think that's so fun?
Yeah, actually, no.
It's sort of a hidden skill of mine, but I'm really good.
What?
It is a skill.
I'm really good at doing store announcements.
I think it would've been really fun!
Moco-chan, sometimes this is the point where it's like, oh, we go to a store and you hear the in-store announcement.
Yes, and I get a bit, a bit angry.
More energy!
Make it interesting!
Right!
The store is closing in five minutes!
Please make your way to the closest register.
Thank you, and have a good night.
You know it!
It's a skill one.
Yeah, I want to direct you where to go.
We hope that you'll check it out if you're visiting Japan soon, Ruffians.
And good luck to those trying to get our novelty cards.
We did put lots of love into them, so hopefully it can reach your paws, too.
BAU BAU!
I forgot.
This is what they look like.
You know you can see Shiori's sample there.
A bit of a sample.
At her signature!
But always a secret.
It's a secret.
I guess.
I guess it's a secret.
Why is always a secret?
Shiori's the leader, she doesn't get to keep secrets.
That's why.
Yeah, but we... I don't know, there's a lot of white space on Shiori's in comparison to ours.
Which is probably good.
I think we made it difficult.
Yeah.
We might have been a bit rough on the staff or something.
Just a bit.
Yeah.
Please try to get your paws on the Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Next, you know, Ruffians.
Today.
Today!
Is that what you wanted?
Yeah.
Today is not December 1st anymore, but it's the first Monday of December.
Which is pretty much the start of December.
The first full week of the final month of the year.
How has your December been so far, Ruffians?
If it could've started better, don't wait, okay?
Just pretend that today is the first day of the month, okay?
And do your best to make December into the month that you can be the most proud of this year, okay?
Yeah, you know, it's cold so you might feel like you just want to kind of curl up and take it easy, but don't give in!
Don't give in, okay?
Get going!
And do those things you want to do.
Yeah, I know FUWAMOCO will be doing the same.
So let's do our best and really have a ton of fun celebrating at the end of the year here in just a few weeks.
There's gonna be so many exciting things!
BAU BAU!
Are you excited?
All the month has been good so far.
Oh, that's good.
Well, it's just gonna get better.
You have the bed right now.
You're in bed right now.
You have a... That's good.
You have until the end of FUWAMOCO Morning to get out of bed.
What?
What if they're going to sleep though?
Oh, if that's the case, then stay in bed.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You know, FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make all together, right?
Right!
Well...
We'd like to ask a little bit more of you.
That's all right.
We need your help, okay?
We need you to let us know if something exciting or silly or interesting happened during our Ien-senpai's streams or on Twitter.
Let us know, okay, with the Twitter new hashtag.
Hashtag FUWAMOCO scoop!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO scoop!
Yeah, for anything, you know, you see something interesting or silly going on, we want to know about it!
You want to know, let us know!
We want to be able to include more about Ien-sanpai and other Advent members during FUWAMOCO Morning, but, you know, sometimes it's kind of hard for us to gather all the news during real time.
I didn't realize.
What?
So, Ruffians, we'll need your help to let us know when there is a scoop that we should kinda dig into.
Or maybe something celebratory going on that maybe us and other Ruffians might have missed.
We'll do our best to include your scoop and let all the other Ruffians know just how on the beat you are with hololive English, okay?
Let's continue to evolve FUWAMOCO Morning together, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Reporters!
Are you reporters or are you detectives?
That's up to you, what kind of journalism you want to provide!
BAU BAU!
I don't know, I'm kind of feeling a little bit more festive now.
It's very December.
Very December!
But, you know, the other day, Mama Puppy, Mama Puppy came by and visited us Ruffians.
You know, she kind of surprised us by saying she wanted to visit suddenly.
But then, it's okay, she'll be really quick because she knows how busy we are and everything.
Well, you know what she did?
She brought a whole bunch of Christmas things for us.
Isn't that nice?
I know there was some special advent calendars that we've had since we were puppies.
A very special festive-smelling candle.
And even a fully-decorated mini Christmas tree!
It was funny.
Do you know why, Ruffians?
Any ideas?
It's because we told Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy a while back that this Christmas is really important to us because, you know, it's the first Christmas that, well, Christmas and New Year, you know, that we get to spend with you!
With you, Ruffians, you know, and we want to be able to spend it with you as much as possible, so that's why Mama Puppy brought those by, so
BAU BAU!
I'm looking forward to it so much.
Well, there's a lot of fun and exciting things going on.
Happy stuff, lots of good stuff, yes.
But, unfortunately, Ruffians!
We had another misunderstanding.
And actually, this time, I don't know Ruffians, you might not have actually noticed it.
Yeah, you might not know about it.
But, so, the other day, right?
We had our Love Live and Idol Master Only Rock n' Rawr Party, right?
And doing one song, Koi ni Naritai Aquarium, we did something a bit different because it's fun!
It's fun!
Rock n' Rawr parties are fun!
Right!
You know, you might have heard us talk about it before, Ruffians, but often for idol lives, there are special words that fans shout out from the audience called calls.
You know, BAU BAU BAU.
You've heard them before, right?
You have.
Right, right?
Yes, calls, calls.
Right.
Yeah.
But, I guess usually, they're at a certain time in the progression of the song.
And, you know, sometimes they're followed with movements.
And, you know, they can sometimes be a bit distracting for some people.
A little bit, maybe.
Yeah, a bit distracting.
But for some, it's really fun and makes you a part of the performance.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, tiger.
Yeah.
Actually, Ruffians, you're not allowed to use this call at official performances.
So if you saw us at our Rock n' Rawr Party and thought, oh, I can go to Tokyo Dome this next week and say, yay, Taiga!
Sorry, you definitely can't.
You know what you can do?
Yes, you can what?
You can yank Tiger during our Rock n' Rawr Party!
Yes, yes!
Because Aqua isn't there.
Too bad.
Yeah, it's not.
It's just FUWAMOCO.
You'll have to be okay with us.
Yeah, and you know Rock n' Rawr Parties aren't held in big venues with lots of venue staff and acoustics.
It's just our studio, you know?
Yeah, we don't have any acoustics where the sound travels at different speeds, you know?
Yeah, it won't cause any issues with us.
Yeah, because we're the performers.
Yeah, yeah.
And I don't think it's going to cause any issues with the Ruffians next to you because I'm pretty sure they're far enough away that they can't hear you.
But... It's okay.
I can't believe it.
You can't do it.
It's because it's not allowed, okay?
Yeah.
You can't do it.
But rock n' rawr parties, it's okay.
It's okay.
But yeah, I can't believe Moco-chan got in trouble with the Yei Taiga police on Twitter.
We were just having fun.
Sorry.
Sorry, Yetiiger, please.
Yetiiger!
What?
BAU BAU.
We were just having fun.
Not officially, you cannot.
Okay?
Not officially, no.
No, but at Rock n' Rawr Parties, yes.
At karaoke, yes.
If you want to sleep during a Rock n' Rawr Party, that's okay.
If you want to just wail during a Rock n' Rawr Party, that's okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
You don't get it!
It makes sense.
It's loud.
It's distracting.
Yeah.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Sorry!
Moco-chan, it's that time of the day!
The start of a new week, the first week of December.
I woke up!
I woke up and you know what the first thing I said was?
Oh no, this is the day I have to eat natto, right?
It was.
I don't want to eat natto today.
Moco-chan!
It's time for you to challenge eating natto again, you know.
It's the first week, the first Monday of December.
And I don't know about you, but natto makes me feel extra festive.
Ruffians.
Will Santa come visit me more if I eat more natto?
I heard that Santa loves natto.
Yeah, he's from Tochigi.
Yeah, Santa's from Tochigi?
Yes, no, yes, no, yes, no, which one, Ruffians?
No, but the Santa from Tochigi would like it even more if you had a natto mix with strawberries from Tochigi, too.
Well, Ruffians, today Moco-chan's gonna once again challenge eating natto.
And if you don't know what natto is, natto is a fermented soybean that's a very common breakfast food in Japan because it's very healthy, very good for you.
There's a healthy vitamin that you can only get from natto.
But it's also very sticky and very smelly and slimy.
It's difficult.
But it's a superfood.
And I want Moco-chan to be able to protect your smile for many, many years, just like me.
So you're going to do your best today, Moco-chan, and eat the natto, okay?
I even got more soy sauce for you, right?
It was good last time with the soy sauce.
No, it was too much with that.
Oh, well.
Wait, did you put it in?
Did you put it in?
I didn't put it in.
Okay, good.
Okay, well, I gotta get it all ready here.
No, that's not the chopsticks I like either.
And while I get it ready, Moco-chan, can you say a big thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who work hard to make this?
Thank you, farmers in Tochigi who work hard to make the natto.
I really appreciate it and I think it's really amazing.
But, I'm not good with natto.
It's done!
I appreciate all your hard work, even though it's difficult for me.
Moco-chan, I'm gonna help you this time, okay?
No, please no.
I don't need help!
Here it goes, FUWAMOCO-chan!
No, stop!
Here it comes!
I don't wanna throw it!
If I put negi in it, it's waste, okay?
Negi wa dame da yo!
Negi ireta.
No onions.
Okay, I guess Moco-chan doesn't need help.
I guess she's an old enough puppy.
Okay, Moco-chan!
How many beans are you gonna- That's the smallest bean.
It's like half a bean!
There's two beans and they're big.
Okay, she has two beans now.
This is good.
Don't make fun of the beans.
Are you ready, Moco-chan?
I'm really not.
Moco-chan, your face looks a little bit more blue than normal.
Does it?
Yeah.
Good luck!
Okay, Moco-chan!
Here we go!
I just wanna drop it down my throat.
That's all you have to do.
Okay!
Three!
No, no, the smell overcame me!
Moco-chan.
Okay!
How am I gonna do this?
You're just gonna do it.
That's how you have to do it.
I don't want to put it in my mouth!
It's like bungee jumping!
Okay, let's do this!
No, no, no, no!
Don't go bungee jumping!
It's not just the smell, okay, Ruffians?
Three!
No, it's not just the smell, it's the taste!
Two!
When I chew it, it's bad.
One!
In it goes!
I can't!
Moco-chan, do it!
Do it!
Chew it!
My face moves away from it.
Go!
Okay, okay, so close, so close, don't smell!
Just do it!
You're making yourself hurt more!
I can't.
Why not?
No, why are you just- Why are you doing that?
Why are you just-
It didn't even... You just touched it!
You just touched it!
No, I can't do it!
I can't do it today!
I touched it with my tongue and I can't do it!
Ruffians, this is getting worse!
That's not a normal reaction, Moco-chan!
I touched it with my tongue!
Are you sure you're not feeling some trauma now?
I can't do it!
This is so much worse.
Are you sure, Moco-chan?
I can't.
Don't.
Stop.
I'm done.
Challenge over.
I did my best.
Happy December.
This is going worse and worse, Ruffians.
No, no, Santa is still.
Santa is still.
Santa is still okay.
Mococo is progressing backwards.
Yeah.
No, it's not December, no way!
This is worse.
No, I did my best.
Thank you.
Poor Natto.
Moco-chan's not trying to be mean.
Eat it later, okay?
You're delicious.
My sister is just silly.
I'm not silly.
Okay, well.
I'm not silly!
I'm Mococo!
Okay.
You good?
I don't want to get not delivered.
There we go.
Well, Ruffians!
Let's head to our regular corner shop.
Next we have Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Clementine!
BAU BAU!
So cute and sleepy.
What an adorable dog.
Look at the dots on her nose and her fuzzy, fuzzy ears!
Very cute.
A very festive Clementine Christmas Orange, right?
Yeah, she looks like she likes to curl up to the fire too.
Very, very cute.
Very cute.
How does Clementine BAU BAU?
I think it would be a sweet and polite BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
But you know Clementine, she's definitely been on her best behavior this year and is looking forward to what Santa might be bringing for her.
Just like me!
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk with... De-den!
It looks really cool.
Look at the sky, it's all orange.
But it's so dark.
It looks a little bit spooky, right?
But you know, you have a smoothie.
You're funny!
Not spooky if you have a smoothie.
Right?
Smoothies keep the spookies away.
Exactly.
Oh, but that's really cool with the signs behind the crazy firelight colors there.
Pretty cool.
It's a bit shocking to like look at the night sky and see that, but... Silent Hill!
Hi!
I think it's good though, you know?
All the cool stuff like the signs and the reasons behind it, so... Yeah.
But, but, please be safe on your walks, okay?
Be okay.
Don't slip.
It looks pretty dark in there, too.
It's dark.
Be safe, okay?
BAU BAU!
Question of the Day!
We have... De-den!
Some time ago you mentioned you wanted to help unite all hololive.
Have you thought of doing some Japanese teaching streamings?
That way English-speaking Ruffians will understand you and your senpais better, and it would be fun to learn from you.
What do you think?
It's a good question.
We'd really love to do more!
We had our
Japanese lesson with Advent, right?
We taught them some important Japanese words and phrases.
It was a lot of fun, but also a lot of work, too.
BAU BAU!
Our brains, they kind of felt like they were going to explode a bit last time.
Just a bit!
But we really want to do more now!
Yeah, it will be fun!
But obviously, you know, our Japanese isn't perfect either, so... No, it won't be perfect.
We do our best.
We may be a bit of a silly sensei.
We might make some mistakes, too.
You think!
Do you think we're just silly?
Silly sensei.
There's not many teachers that will teach you some kind of words.
But we would like to be able to try teaching English to some of our JP senpais too!
Ruffians, do you have any ideas for a senpai that you think would like an English lesson from FUWAMOCO?
Biboo.
Biboo knows English.
I think maybe Biboo could teach us some English.
Mikocchi-senpai.
Poruru-oneechan.
She doesn't seem very into it.
Why?
Pekora.
Pekora-senpai.
She's busy with her concert.
She doesn't have time to learn English right now.
Kaie-senpai.
That would be cute.
We'll have to think about it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the question!
And thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today.
And we'll be counting on you as we ask
BAU BAU!
De-den!
I don't really know much about the game yet.
But it seems like it's very addicting.
Yeah, I'm just looking forward to seeing how much passion we'll get to, you know?
We hope you'll join us, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Wow, this week we have a lot of exciting things going on, but on Friday we have a collab together with all of Advent.
We're playing Blade Up, but this time at the end we have a big announcement for you!
We hope that you'll be there to hear it right from us, and that you'll look forward to it too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Wow, but before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Haita!
BAU BAU!
Shuumachi!
Yuki!
BAU BAU!
Eldoree!
Early!
BAU BAU!
Zephyr!
Ian Fazian!
BAU BAU!
Isrun!
Is!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!